this is 2006 he comes into my office and
sits down and it's the room set up like
a like a living room right so we're both
in comfy chairs about three feet apart
so closer than you and I are now right
and I go mark you don't know me
I've been around a long time let me give
you a little context for how I'm looking
at this meeting because once you start
talking
you're gonna interpret everything I said
as though I'm just reacting to what you
say so let me go first
he goes go ahead then I go if it hasn't
already happened either Microsoft or
Yahoo is gonna offer a billion dollars
for Facebook no it turns white
well everybody everybody who's listening
this may wonder why that was significant
they just finished a nine million dollar
revenue year right right basically doing
this banner ads for pizza it's a 100
million dollar company at that point no
it was a nine million dollars in row 9
million revenue but a hundred million
dollar valuation maybe take a guess
three hundred I don't think so no yeah
no and they've taken the money from what
you know sorry it may be a hundred it
was whatever the Excel valuation was
which I feel isn't he yeah whatever
whatever the number was a billion
dollars was huge so I learned one of
these guys is gonna offer you a billion
dollars and everybody you know your
parents your board of directors Jim
Breyer from Excel your management team
you're in place everybody's gonna say
mark take money sure your own 60 70
percent of the company well you're gonna
have six hundred fifty billion dollars
you're gonna change the world
Jim Breyer it's gonna tell you he's
gonna fund your next company you're just
gonna do it again rocker off everybody's
gonna tell you they're gonna go with yet
it's gonna be fantastic and I just want
you to know someone work I think
Facebook is gonna be more successful
than Google as today so Google of 2000
yeah 2006 and I said which was a big
number and I said I believe you've
broken the code that in social media the
thing we know is that anonymity breeds
trolls which undermines the viability of
a social network because at that time he
doesn't even have newsfeed yet in it's
just a Facebook and it's just high
school high school and college students
so he's got a Santa Katie
identity hmm because you have to have
the the email address from the school
and I'm thinking that is gonna provide a
form of protection against trolls that
nobody else has ever had and they're
going
I think authenticated identity plus the
ability of people to control the privacy
Relf - who can see what those things
gonna let you scale this thing and make
you eventually more important than
Google is today and I said so here's the
thing nobody in Silicon Valley ever has
the perfect idea at the perfect time
twice and I think you have the perfect
idea at the perfect time so if you
believe this idea if you really believe
in your vision you should recognize that
Microsoft or Yahoo or anybody else is
gonna just trash this thing and you
probably won't get another shot to do
something as cool as this so if you
believe the vision when that offer comes
in you should be prepared to say no it
took me two minutes to do that what
followed was the most painful five
minutes of my entire life
and I've had life-saving surgery and
I've had a bunch of traumatic injuries
this was the most painful fight that
I've just laid this really heavy thing
on him right and I'm expecting feedback
right I get dead silence and I'm in a
room that is soundproof - with an inch
of its life I mean it is so dead I mean
you it was eerie and he goes through all
these pantomiming motions of thinking
all right and he's not saying a word and
so for the first minute I'm thinking
myself wow he's really listening
wow he's good either he's really
thinking about this this is he's paying
me a compliment I'm really cool but I
gotta be honest with you if you've ever
sat with somebody like if I just sit
here go yeah it's it's disconcerting
after five or six seconds you start to
get nervous right so if the one minute
mark I'm going this is getting weird at
two minutes I'm going this is really
weird
at three minutes I've digging my
fingernails into the furniture just
trying to contain myself because I mean
this is going on so long I've never had
experiences at four minutes I'm
literally ready to scream and sometime
in the fifth minute he visibly relaxes
he's decided he's gonna trust me for the
purposes of this meeting and he goes you
won't believe this but that thing you
just said that's why I'm here
that exact thing has just happened one
of those guys was offered two billion I
was offered about yeah
got blood turns out Yahoo had offered a
billion dollars he doesn't say that time
just says one of those two guys was
offered a billion dollars and everything
you said that his Lily just happened
that's why I'm here so we had this
really weird thing where the meetings
infect inverted right that instead of
him coming and tell me a story and
asking my advice and not being sure
everything and trust me I've anticipated
the entire thing
he's decide he's trust me before he's
even told me right so it the whole
meeting like I did immediately the whole
meeting last half an hour because I said
to him do you want to sell and he goes I
really don't want to disappoint our
buddy and I go dude that's not the
question the question is do you want to
sell it do you believe in your vision he
goes no I really believe in the vision I
go well do you want my help and he goes
I'm that's why I'm here I need your help
so it took in he had a golden vote so it
was just a question of framing the
message he was gonna give to everybody
to get them to say to understand that
hey they're all gonna thank Mark for not
selling the company because he's gonna
achieve a thing that's a hundred million
active users right something that would
be worth 200 times this some huge
multiple yeah and so he leaves after
half an hour and the Evite's me over to
his office like the next day or a couple
days later and that begins this this
thing because he has a core problem at
that point his whole management team
wanted to sell the company so he
couldn't very well keep all the people
would be wanting to sell the company so
I had a mission which was he obviously
wasn't gonna turn to the other people on
his insider list for that help because
they'd wanted to sell it to he would be
worried that they would bring in people
who would wanted to sell it again and so
I had for a brief period of time I have
this special relationship that I'm the
guy who didn't who didn't want him to
sell and so you know we have to replace
the CFO and the chief operating officer
and some other positions but we also had
the wincle vie
that whole thing blows up right away and
again I have no opportunity at that
point to invest because he's just taking
the money from Jim Brier tax hell he
doesn't need any money and it didn't
matter to me because I'm going this I
think this is the next coolest thing
since Google and he was interesting my
help
plus he was such a cool guy I mean
socially awkward definitely but he was a
great listener and he's he's brilliant
unbelievably so is that his superpower
his focus yeah
no no and the thing is I every
experience I had with him was fantastic
and that's the thing I transplant buddy
I really liked him and still do and it's
like I feel terrible that things have
gotten so weird because he's a really
interesting guy and what he created on
its own terms is simply magnificent